they say one man's trash is another
man's treasure but for one resident of
Queens New York
trash is an inspiration and his artistic
medium John Norwood has created hundreds
of works of art from raw materials that
would otherwise go straight to the
landfill and he's inviting everyone to
have a look this is all your work Oh
John Norwood wanted his art to be out in
the world how many square feet at all
16,000 16 so he turned his house into a
museum the Norwood Museum it's quite a
body of work and you haven't even seen
half of it John and his wife Ruby live
on a quiet road in College Point Queens
overlooking the landing path to
LaGuardia Airport the Norwood museum is
not in most New York City guidebooks
he's on TripAdvisor for college point so
that helps you got very good reviews on
TripAdvisor five stars I wrote them all
[Laughter]
Norwoods been making things all his life
for 25 years he worked for renowned
architect IM Pei I made architecture
models and run a shop of about 15 people
working on the East Wing of the National
Gallery in Washington the Javits Center
in New York the Kennedy Library in
Boston the pyramid Alou was one of the
last things that worked on in retirement
he returned to his art these
self-portraits are from the 1960s what
have you got going up here that's my old
shoes I had to go up and down a lot of
20 times to get those shoes up on the
roof now 81 he works mostly with garbage
I'm hoping that you didn't smoke all the
cigarettes in the cigarette box
unfortunately I did we will not talk
about it at 81 Ruby is still a
practicing pediatrician she was trying
to throw out a perfectly good shopping
bag the other day
you didn't see the potential in it the
artistic potential potential okay
sometime I think I'm a junior sometimes
I ain't got my data yet you're just
gonna keep making stuff aren't you car
drops which means the museum may soon
need a new wing knock on wood
do we have any wood anywhere else no me
nor would these do no you know it's just
so remarkable to see the the connection
between the two of them yes and but and
what Ruby puts up with this creative
explosion actually a fire destroyed
almost everything in 2009 but as you can
see John has gone back to work and the
crazy house is full again I want to
invite Ruby and Johnny Easter brunch
tomorrow so if you're in Queens stop by
god